Build it.Draw It. Play It.
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people. This
is BiDiPi.
Build it
Gabriel Dishaw is making new art out of old
mechanical objects. He uses parts from typewriters,
adding machines, and any old computers or
technology. His hope is to be able to continue
to upcycle old items and help create a way
to deal with discarded technology. He has
several different genres including a skull
series, table top sculptures, and figurative
sculptures.
Matthieu Georger makes these amazing and elaborate
Origami designs. Some of the designs are based
off of other renowned Origami artists and
some are of his own creation. He has hundreds
of these folded works of art including this
dragon, a centipede, buddha, and a minotaur.
Jeff Wright is a balloon artist who lives
in Bolivia doing charity work. He was challenged
to make an Iron Man 3 balloon suit with less
than 500 balloons. He ended up finishing it
in just under 10 hours and used 364 balloons.
Draw it
Mike Alcantara of comic collage art uses pieces
of old comics to recreate comic book heroes.
All of his one-of-a-kind artworks are made
entirely of comics and they include Captain
America, The Joker, and Conan The Barbarian.
DJRoomba created Game of Thrones Sigils for
every NFL team. Many have multiple designs
such as the Buffalo's Bowed, Bent, Broken.
New England; By any means necessary, and San
Francisco Gold for our Glory, Red for Your
Blood.
And now for the Street Fighter chronicles
art from Arman Akopian...
Photographer Joseph Ford made these clever
photos that mash up aerial landscapes with
fashion photography. He used aerial images
he had previously shot and worked with an
art director and stylist to come up with matching
fashion that would easily merge into the landscapes.
Some of the images took up to 12 hours to
match the fabrics and prints with the backgrounds.
Play it
Iron Horse Bluegrass has a ton of great covers
and tributes - here's their version of Enter
Sandman by Metallica.
In his own effort to keep Portland weird the
Darth Vader Unicycler rides while playing
the Star Wars theme on his flaming bagpipes.
Here's a cool system that allows the audio
of NES games to be played through an acoustic
player piano and robotically controlled percussive
instruments.
Finally here is the incredible music video
for Cruz Del Sur by RVSB.
Submit your BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube. Or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio. Music created and submitted
by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to just your creations. And as always
- thanks for watching.